すっげえ結婚ブームが来てるなあ！
なんか、すごい色々な人が結婚してるよ
これはもう言うしかないな！
あの、この勢いに乗って言います
私「はじめしゃちょー」は、え～来月の２月の14日に...
結婚しま
せーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーん
多分皆さんも通ったことある道だと思おもうんですけど
絵本というものがございます
絵がかいてある本なんですけども、なんかねー...
泣きたいなぁ～って思って
僕の事知ってる人ならわかると思うんですけど
すごい泣いちゃうんです
涙もろいところがありまして
結構なんかアニメとか映画とか
高校バスケの引退試合とか見ても
泣いてるぐらいちょっと
いろいろ泣いちゃうんですけども
絵本の中では
泣ける絵本がすごい多いみたいで...
で、ちょっといろいろ調べた結果ですね
泣ける絵本ランキングとかなんか色んなのがあって
近くの本屋さんに行って、ちょっと泣ける本を
何冊か今回買ってきました！
あの僕いくらね、その涙もろいっつっても
さすがに 絵本では泣かない！！
なんか、動画とか、こう動きがあるものじゃないと
やっぱ僕泣けないんです、たぶん
（風の音にビビるはじめしゃちょー）
すげー風強いな
こんな僕が果たして
すごい泣けるような本を何冊か準備したので
それで本当に泣けるのかどうかを
今回検証してみたいと思います
やばいよ
23歳の大人が絵本読んで泣いてたら
もう・・・ねえ・・・！！
一冊目はこちらです
100万回生きたねこ
「これって恋のはなしだね」
これってね
たぶんねオイラ読んだことある
気がする
この顔見覚えあるもん
200万部売れてるみたいでございます
これはねなんかね
口コミにあったというか
なんか王道の泣ける話みたいな絵本らしいので
早速読んでいきたいと思います。
100万回も死なない猫がいました...
（早送り>>>）
ア‘‘ア‘‘
読むだけだから何も期待しないでね・・
泣けるかどうかの検証ですからね
（早送り>>>>>）
朝になって夜になって
ﾃﾚ⤴⤴ﾃﾚ⤴⤴ﾃﾚ⤴⤴ﾃﾚ⤴⤴ﾃﾝ
ﾋｭﾝｯ!（字幕が消える音）
ある日のお昼に・・・（早送り>>>>>）
う〜〜〜〜〜ん
危ねえ・・・
いやぁ、いい話ですね〜
普通にいい話だった。
絵もあるんですけど
言葉が一言一言短いから、力があるんですよね
一文ずつに 俺は何の話をしてんだ・・・
いや、本当になんか最後の方の一文で
ちょっと急にグッっときちゃったんで
びびったんですけど
ほんと、いい話でした・・・
ただ泣きはしなかったぐらい
でもとても素敵なお話でしたね
つぎ！！！！！！！！
次はこちら
ずーっとずっとだいすきだよ
小学校の教科書に選ばれてるみたいですね〜
こうゆうちょっとねえ、大好きだよ系はちょっとねえ、怖いっスねえ
まあ言うて絵本なんで
大丈夫っしょ！
エルフは世界で一番素晴らしい犬です・・・
（早送り>>>>>）
ぼくは エルフィンに やわらかい枕をやって
んん！
はい、読みます
ｽﾞｷｭｩﾝ!（ハートを撃ち抜かれた音）
うぅうぅうぅ
マジかぁ～エルフィンゥ
ｱｧ~
・・・ずっとずっと大好きだよって・・・
うわああああああ
授業中みんな泣いちゃうよぉぉぉぉぉぉ
ふぇぇ・・・
うぉ↑ぅ↓うぉ↑ぅ↓うぉ↑ぅ↓
ああ・・・クソぅ！
やばいなぁ
ちょっと！俺も歳取ったなあ
涙腺が弱すぎるんですけど
実は ぼく子供の頃にジョンっていう犬がいたんですよ
実家にね
なんかねペットと人間のその～
あるじゃないですか、信頼関係とか
グッと来たものがありました
いやぁ～よかった
すげぇなこんなの小学生読んでんの？
授業中でこんなの音読したら
みんなでスタンディングオベーションの
拍手大喝采だよ
まじで！
絵本で普通に泣いちゃうんだけども
最後はこちらです
ていう絵本なんですけども
すごいッスね55万部売れてるみたいですね
これはなんかね子供向けというより
なんかそのお母さんとかね
大人の人が見てもこうなんか
すごい感動するみたいで
めちゃくちゃなんかTOPに上がってたんで
ひょっとしたらこれが最強なのかもしれません
フゥ～
絵本いいねぇ///
さっそく読んでいきたいと思います
ではっ！
（早送り>>>>>>>>）
おおおぉぉぉ～・・・
いや すごいでも いい話でした
良かったです 良かったです（拍手）
ぼく思ったんですけど
これ多分ねぇ、あのぉ～
お母さんが読んだら
すごい泣けるのかなって思いました
いや、なんか僕も母ちゃんのこと
想いながら読んだんですけど
いやぁ、グッと来ますねえ
ぇっ・・・後から来るぞこれ
後から来るパターンかもしれない
いやぁ～良かったです、すごい
なんか全然ね、方向性が違ったね
僕はこれが1番泣けたんですけども
やっぱなんかペットとかね
僕、はまだ子どもがいないので
多分ね、まだそんなに心から入ることは、ちょっとまだできなかったんですけども
ペットとかいろいろ飼ってたんで
こっちはすごい共感できたんで
グッと来ましたね
というわけで
結果
絵本は
いつ見てもいいものだよ
テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ…♪
TE・TE・TE・TEN☆